terrifying I hate for them well then I'm
not playing anymore
[Music]
it's Karen and Connie and yes we're
twins what as twins we get a lot of
weird questions about twin theories
specifically things like you feel each
other's pain do you guys have your own
language but the thing people want to
know the most is if we have telepathy
so it's let the thing is the thing where
people believe that we can communicate
with only our minds the only things that
I've ever thought I wonder if she can
actually hear what's going on in here is
whenever I'm thinking of a song and all
of a sudden you'll start seeing it
that's true or sometimes I have felt
like anxious if you feel anxious or
excited when you feel excited and that
could just be like being around you but
what if it's something more so we're
gonna put it to the test today and we
are going to try to see if we actually
do have telepathy I'm looking for a way
to test this I of course went to Google
and found out that in the 1930s there
was a test that they actually did to
look for telepathy and it's called the
Zener cards Duke psychologist Carl
sinner and JD Rhine designed for five
unique cards for experimental
extrasensory perception research in one
version of their experiments the tester
would hold the back of the card up to
the subject and then ask the subject to
guess which design was on the front of
the card we're gonna do a test based off
of today how many of these do we have to
get right have slept with probability
states that will at least get a v IVs
right so if we get more than like one or
two pretty good all right let's do this
it was really intense it's supposed to
be okay so I'm going to go first I am
going to select a card at random and
Connie is going to decide which card she
thinks it is we're both gonna set them
down to the side and see at the end we
got right and now we're gonna shuffle
every day I'm shuffling
oh I picked the card but really look at
it and think about it okay okay got any
sixes what you made
yes all right we only have three three
luck okay you ready to show so we'll
start with the last card you did first
ready to what okay one's a fluke it
makes like I've ever seen so we know
that another one in here has to be wrong
that's true I genuinely I'm like already
shocked by this - what
I'm not gonna lie I'm a little like
light-headed guys I'm serious we are not
cheating
which means this one's definitely a bust
right so there's another okay this is
another one of the three out of five I
mean okay so we're gonna do the same
thing this round but this time I'm gonna
be picking the cards and Karen's going
to be trying to match them through our
minds okay so ready got it this is for
twins everywhere so the stakes could not
be higher okay yep
sound sound is just for fun okay okay
okay three two one you know what yeah
yeah you know what actually just go
ahead yeah it is guys that was in sync
I do feel a little bit like we have a
superpower now like a little bit so now
that we know that one twin myth is
probably true pick me a little bit
worried that the others are like maybe
we can feel each other's pain don't saw
it coming a mile away
maybe we do have telepathy
[Music]